georgia has passed this this new voter
law
that's going to try to tighten up some
of the ridiculous
shenanigans that the democrats voiced it
on that system
leading up to 2020. so the
the big headline here is that in georgia
now you're not allowed to bring
food and water to people waiting in line
to vote
shocking oh this is to suppress the vote
this is this is a white supremacist
i don't know why but everything's white
supremacist now uh no it's
common sense there are very strict rules
around polling places at least there
used to be now i guess
we've gotten rid of election day we've
gotten rid of in-person voting as the
primary way to vote so now you know
it's it's up for grabs
usually being grabbed by democrats but
in the olden days of a couple years ago
we had strict rules around polling
places because we know
that voting is so susceptible to fraud
and it's very important in our country
and so we want to protect it
there were rules about how campaign
workers
can interact with people as they wait in
line to vote namely they can't
there are rules around where signs for
candidates can go
near polling places they can't be very
close because you want to keep
this area protected from the
machinations of party politics
in the old days of the democrat machines
tammany hall
boss tweed you would have operatives go
up to people waiting to vote or grabbing
people to vote and they say hey i'll
give you a free drink
if you go vote for my guy hey yeah show
up to the bar later you get a free drink
if you vote for my guy
hey here's a little food hey here's a
little drink hey here's a little you're
just buying votes
so george is reiterating a view that has
been widely held re reiterating laws
that have been on the books for a long
time
and saying yeah you can't do that you
can't buy votes that's the rule
let's say that when you go to vote it
takes more than
half an hour generally when i've voted
it takes about
half an hour maybe it's a little bit
longer that's taking up to an hour maybe
in california
let's say it's even longer let's say
it's two hours
let's say i'm going to give the crazy
left the benefit of the doubt
let's say it's three hours wait in line
to vote
let first of all if you really get
famished during that time or you really
get thirsty
bring a bottle of water shove a granola
bar in your pocket
but let's say let's say you forgot
if you cannot go three hours without
stuffing your face
something is wrong with you something
has you need to put the cupcake down
if you cannot go three hours without
having a little nibble
our bodies were made to go more than
three hours
without a muffin you will survive
i promise you you will survive but of
course these are not
these are not the real concerns of
democrats in georgia
or the national democrats looking at
georgia they want to be able to buy
votes and to get really close to the
polling place when they can't pry people
away from the polling place in the first
place and get them to vote by mail
and maybe get a few of their dead
cousins to vote by mail too
it's all about it's about race this is
do you know it's white supremacy
to prevent democrat operatives from
bribing voters with drinks and
candies and things cnn's dana bash was
shocked horrified it's too bad i
actually kind of like dana bash she's
done some
some pretty good interviews recently but
she just goes back to that typical
democratic narrative very often
she was shocked and appalled that
georgia governor brian kemp would sign
this new vote integrity bill
in a room of that of the worst
beast that has ever roamed the earth
white
men joining me now is democratic georgia
senator reverend raphael warnock senator
reverend thank you so much for joining
me this morning i want to put
up that picture of governor brian kemp
signing this law in a room full of white
men
a room full of white men he's saying
that we can't send our operatives to go
give people slices of pizza at the polls
in a room full of white men everyone
knows white men don't need to eat
everyone it's just basic science white
men don't need water to survive
it's so all these white men they know
they know that if they they deprive
voters of color
of snacks at the polling play know that
they will suppress the vote
imagine i mean it's become cliche i
don't i almost don't want to say it but
imagine if somebody went
forget on cnn let's say somebody on on a
conservative news channel went out and
said
you know i can't believe that uh that
this
well we'll refer to the true governor of
georgia stacy abrams i still think she
hasn't conceded that race from a couple
years ago
if if a conservative went on tv and said
can you believe that stacey abrams
signed
this bill into law in a room full of
black women ugh
makes me sick terrible
could you imagine the reaction but of
course there's they're not playing fair
so it's
it's almost pointless even to mention it
everything even the least racially
relevant questions need to come down to
race
when it is in any way convenient
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
[Music]